la parole est à monsieur andré richard
pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole pour deux minutes
mon cher collègue se le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre l'intérieur sur le
ministre le gouvernement a annoncé que
dans le cadre de l'organisation de la
coop 21 les contrôles aux frontières
seront rétablis du 13 novembre au 13
décembre
cette mesure autorisée par les accords
schengen est motivée par la volonté
d'éviter l'entrée sur notre territoire à
la fois de terroristes potentiels attiré
par l'importance des délégations
étrangères présentes pour l'événement et
de groupes altermondialistes violent
souhaitant perturbé notamment l'errance
et des rassemblements de la coalition
climat prévue à cette occasion je
souhaite genesis vous poser deux
questions à cet égard dans un premier
temps j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous
indiquer comment concrètement ces
contrôles ressent père est sur le
terrain allez-vous rétablir les postes
frontières antérieures
rien qu'en alsace plus de 70 mille
travailleurs frontaliers souhaite le
savoir ensuite si l'on peut penser que
les contrôles décourageront
effectivement certaines entrées ne
pensez vous pas que pour l'essentiel les
éventuels terroristes ou fauteurs de
troubles sont déjà en place dans notre
pays si l'on en juge notamment parce que
font les no border à calais depuis trois
jours où par la récente arrestation d'un
candidat terroristes à toulon je vous
remercie
aulas et à bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre
oui monsieur le sénateur votre question
permettent d'apporter des
éclaircissements sur la décision qui a
été prise par le gouvernement français
dans la perspective de cette grande
conférence internationale et qui est une
décision d'ailleurs qui s'apparentent à
celles comprises pris d'autres
gouvernements dans des circonstances
comparables je pense à l'allemagne à
l'occasion d'un récent sommet
international ou d'autres pays à
accueillir la conférence climat nous
n'allons pas fermer les frontières
contrairement à ce que certains ont
prétendu instrumentalisant cette
décision de raisons pour faire de la
propagande électorale de mauvaise
qualité
nous allons mettre en place des
contrôles aux frontières pendant un mois
comme le prévoit les articles 23 à 25 du
code frontière schengen de manière à
prévenir l'intrusion sur le territoire
national d'individus qui pourrait
représenter un risque
vous me dites comment vont se passer ces
contrôles je vous réponds très
clairement nous allons mobiliser
treize mille de nos fonctionnaires hi-fi
essentiellement pour 26 milles entre eux
la direction centrale de la sécurité
publique est compagnies de crs des
acteurs de la direction centrale de la
police de l'air et des frontières pour
procéder entre le 13 et le 19 novembre à
des contrôles mobiles et aléatoire qui
ne perturberont en rien la possibilité
de mouvement de ceux qui sont
transfrontaliers nous allons renforcer
ses contrôles
dix jours avant les deux manifestations
des 29 novembre et 12 décembre et quatre
jours avant ces manifestations
les contrôles sont plus systématiques
donc nous aurons des moyens nous aurons
de la sécurité et nous n'aurons pas pour
ceux qui traversent la frontière
quotidiennement de conséquences en
termes de mobilité
voilà très exactement comment nous
allons le faire vous me dites ensuite
cela ne vous reste qu'un que secondes
cela n'empêchera pas des terroristes ou
des acteurs violent d'elle sur le
territoire national oui il y en a et
nous prenons toutes dispositions pour
éviter qu'ils ne nuisent à l'instar de
ce que nous avons fait travers
l'arrestation de toulon mais nous
éviterons que d'autres viennent
s'ajouter à eux pouvant se trouver à
l'origine de très graves troubles à
l'ordre public
merci monsieur andré richard mais
monsieur le ministre vous ne m'avez
malheureusement pas rassuré je vous
rappelle que lors du sommet de l'otan à
strasbourg le rétablissement des
contrôles aux frontières n'avait pas
empêché les important débordement qu'on
a connu ensuite depuis le début de
l'année vous le savez au moins 800 mille
migrants sont entrés en europe schengen
sont jamais avoir été recensés un
contrôle temporaire d'un mois et d'alors
aussi illusoire keane opérant comme les
mesures pour contenir la pression
migratoire à savoir bouclage douaniers
quotas d'accueil centre porte de l'union
incitations retours sont inefficaces il
ya urgence à repenser la notion de
frontière et de passer à autre chose que
schengen pour assurer la sécurité de nos
concitoyens
on entend malheureusement pas assez le
gouvernement français sur ce sujet merci